hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play vanish
okay there is an ending to this game
someone have informed me that I need to
go through it all the way to the end I
don't want to but I'm going to also I
want to comment yet this game was made
by a company called three drunk men and
that appeals to me deep in my heart if
you all follow my drunk minecraft so I'm
going to play it to completion if it
kills me
which it might but anyway this is like I
really I really do like how well this
game is made I mean I've played you guys
know that I played some crappy horror
games in the past but to see something
like this is really really cool to me
and it is randomly generated see is CC
Eustis sorry for yelling
I'm sorry monsters in the dark it is
randomly generated because I went left
last time and there was an F yeah okay I
don't want to play this this was like it
back when I first played se Poh 7b
that's what this reminds me of like just
pushing myself like I don't want to keep
moving forward but I have to because you
guys are making me and I really like it
I don't like it but I like it
okay anyway enough jibber jabbering time
to get down to business there's monsters
in the darkness that need to be tamed so
we can use them for raw labor and slave
in the overworld let's just stick to
surviving the attacks for now and then
wolf then we'll work on enslaving them
the mole people I'm guessing is what
we're gonna call them because they think
that's what they are I think they're the
mole people
hello note that's click right click did
you piss down here something smells
maybe because it's actually a sewer is
shitty glow suits I don't have any glow
sticks I needed to pick them up
Oh eeny meeny miny not that way okay
let's go down the darkened hallway cuz
that's smart film I did cuz I know that
those little bastard thingies just like
to creep off just out of sight and they
move by sound echolocation okay eenie
meenie miney moe catch up not that way
okay this way again hello another note
Hank I'm not sure what's going on oh I'm
getting a static on the radio and you
said we'd never need these notepads
alright no time to go crazy no time to
go crazy gotta keep moving forward oh
come on
branches what is this a maze all right
I'm just gonna keep turning right and if
there's ever failed me I like how it
gets scared my field of view just kind
of like suddenly super wide oh that way
why oh it's a dead end okay then that
that's a good explanation as to why yeah
that's very good
Oh
which way wasn't saying this Wiggy okay
no thank you
I made it to the generator glow sticks
okay all right all right how many do I
have
oh no use it I press F oh there we go
oh he shook it okay that's good no no
aah no way in hell holy crap this way
how about this way this is better thank
you
okay just a leak I'm gonna take this
very slow he's so creepy
what honey everybody shut up everybody
just shut up
which way did I come from you think this
way
ouch down why are they down every
hallway Oh No
well let clothes stick didn't help much
anyway I'll make it okay it's already
seriously this scholastic does not help
just gonna say that right now I don't
even know what I need oh let's just go
ah crap do kill me
where did you come from I'm gonna make
sure you go far okay I think it's gone I
think it's good why why why why why why
why
why would you do that randomly you
probably wasn't random I think there was
actually something there where do these
things go they just come and just
disappear as quickly as they arrive I'm
gonna walk through the rest of this game
just crouched just crouch that was one
down there before
I'm gonna check behind me make sure
there's not behind me
it's apparently they do that Hey look
get still there okay going backwards
please don't sandwich me and I will kill
you until you so dead I hear whispering
oh no that's not good that's not a good
sound oh man this game is so it's hard
it's hard to understand the tangible
difference between a game that can truly
scare you but it mostly has to do with
the immersion like how never mind I
don't know what I'm talking about I
don't know if I've gone down this way
before glowstick
oh come on no not again not again
why what did i do differently why
suddenly then
I'm okay I'm okay there's an ending to
this game all right let me hang on let
me collect my thoughts for different cuz
I want to say something about the
scaring it works differently from person
to person and it works differently from
game to game there is not one tangible
thing that can say what causes a game to
be scary like this and actually it's
hard to say what makes this one more
scary than a lot of other games I've
played I have this sense of dread this
overwhelming sense of dread that it's
gonna kill me randomly from anywhere and
I'm always wrong I think no matter what
that's the feeling I get when I'm moving
through these halls and it's amazing it
really is I'm flabbergasted that it is
because like I said back when I first
played when I first played SCP I ate
some I no idea what to expect out of it
and just poop making yourself push down
every new level and making yourself push
down every new corridor in this game and
it's just like you it's it's a hurdle
that you have to push over in your heart
where it's like okay just keep going I
know it's down there but keep going like
making yourself that's what it is and
that's what a lot of crap no don't do
that that's what a lot of games you have
to make the player not want to move
forward and then make himself move
forward that I think that is like the
key and how you do that is totally
intangible but this game is good at it
okay
okay anyway I thought I thought for
single a all right I can sprint now it's
probably okay oh now I'm hearing the
whispers look as soon as your vision
starts to go with it's too soon you
can't bring the monsters in too soon I
didn't even find a hidey hole last time
hey Phil my radios busted heading back
to access ladder to grab a replacement
it's too soon to have the mantras is it
isn't eeny meeny miny straight ahead
well I don't you know when I first
started playing like SC poh 7b I played
that before containment breach and I
don't know if that's still anywhere to
be found but someone wants to see me
being like I haven't been like this
apprehensive of moving forward since I
played that and that may have been on a
live stream that may have been recorded
I don't know I think it was on the live
stream but I'm not just certain okay all
right then I just I swear I keep seeing
that it's gonna be a dead end right in
front of me
Holliday generator room uh-huh safe
haven of the jabber a room I don't think
it's that safe with whatever was that
glowy thing okay so anyway I don't know
what my objective is I'm just gonna
start heading down this path hope it
doesn't kill me and then move on with my
life stop that
okay why are all the lights broken that
is not fair chicka chicka hey don't be a
dead end
oh if you're a dead end you dick I
squared it Hank where are you are you
getting my notes I don't even know where
I am I think there's something down here
with us I'm still looking for the water
pump room to help look for your keys
okay looking for the water pump room the
water pump room I'm not sure if the
whispers said I'm hearing our clue to
where they are or if they're just trying
to kill me I think they're trying to
kill me why
oh please run faster need to get back to
the safe haven of the generator room
that's happened before I think that
scripted I think that scripted that way
to have him standing right on that
corner stop [ __ ] Fair where's the
generator room I swear I was I swear the
generator room was this way yeah crap
which way did I just go oh this is this
is bad okay am i safe am i safe am i
safe
no running not even gonna give you a
chance buddy
I'm not even gonna give you a chance to
wrap your long slender fingers spread
you about gird run something is it by me
okay running running running running
running running with aah
which way do I go this way
oh I swear this gaem was such a troll
it puts sounds all around me but they're
not really there are they are they
no they're not
it changes on demand
it changes I swear I swear to god I'm
going insane I'm going superb aha I
stopped trying to run I thought
seriously this is ah
the game it changes that's not fair
the game can't change as I'm playing it
why I wanna play Ellen I don't want to
play no one play anymore I'm gonna play
this game skate was terrifying
I'm gonna go hug a puppy smells and
flowers look at kittens why is it for
yourself if you don't believe me like
there are always some people that are
skeptical that I've liked playing it up
or faking it or doing something
seriously play this game it's even worse
now knowing that it actually does change
everything when you're playing it cuz I
went down that same hallway it was not a
dead end
you guys saw for yourself this game is
good play it for yourself get in a dark
room headphones turn up the volume and
play it alone while not talking into a
camera see how well you do anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
end faces for more videos if I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
we're banging on my door
maybe